a ajuda chega
onde vai o mundo assim a escalação pode
ir à loteria
a nossa idéia é bom sempre pega o outro
onde a julho inclusive viajar na segunda
guerra pode sempre foi meu sonho é claro
favorito
ae
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ae
dirigir
[Música]
será uma chance eu faço juízo só olha só
que a venda ilegal carregada de bola e
entender qual é a colega está na lista
do que seus irmãos e deixa a bola
[Música]
mas a jovem só dele
a bola parecia um show que eu fiz em
caxias no maranhão eo segundo foi o que
eu fiz aqui em teresina no dia 20 de
julho às sete horas da noite vou fazer
um fortaleza no teatro via sul no
shopping ea sucata vendendo os ingressos
só chegar à bilheteria do teatro insular
no shopping via sul fica no terceiro
piso do shopping e assunto é comprar seu
ingresso e dia 20 e na inter porque está
postando um vídeo porque eu to com
problema na garganta e este problema é o
seguinte quanto mais eu falo mas ele
pior quanto mais um esforço da avó eo
pai dele pior então já está marcada a
cirurgia pelo mesmo problema é a
cirurgia pode ser que talvez eu vá me
encontrar nos braços de jesus brincar e
é coisa rápida besteira e para fazer a
cirurgia todo mundo tem que fazer um
monte de exames em um monte de coisa e
eu fui fazendo quem conhece sabe que eu
tenho um pavor de agulha essa espada que
essa espada que só é trair ela minha
roupa não tenho medo dela agora vejo
agulha tipo
mas comigo
o efeito esperado na minha bunda
melancia é bonita e foi tirar sangue
para cruzar furar aqui em cima da cabeça
o gol de caio botou negou assim puxou um
pouco de sangue
botou do negócio joel de sangue botou
negócio com chopin condição bom todo
negócio puxou medo de ser foi não fazer
molho pardo com meu sangue eo engraçado
que o sangue que sai no primeiro biel -
antes a no segundo por que não dividir o
som e fez aí fiz esse outro dia fui
fazer o teria gente na sata la nina
vocês sabem o que fazem no computador ea
mãe se não ela me ensinando ela hoje a
estagiar a menina que autorizavam o
exame era estagiário a levá-lo a mudança
não vai autorizar o exame de próstata
pra mim aqui no botão errado é um é o
que na garganta a próxima e eu pensando
que o mundo da ciência assim os
micróbios - quando o micro organismo
vivo está todo momento ativos todos
trabalham para que a doença se agrave e
um olhar feminino oi aperta onde 17 até
errado 18 voltas de novo não sei que o
meu dedo acesso aumenta treinando eu tô
morrendo a cada segundo é voltado a
fingir que estava no red star disputada
no estádio assim ele passou a sentir a
pressão até fiquei com medo de deus dá
uma pressão de verdade eu morri mas é
mais sérias que contabiliza ai ai estou
falecendo me tome morrendo
a doença está se dando me a mim get to
morrendo no hospital não adianta muito
você dizer que está morrendo até porque
todo mundo lá tá morrendo nas pessoas lá
justamente pra isso pra não morrer em ti
eu sou medroso internacional sub-21 sou
eu sou muito medroso tão medroso que eu
vou tomar inalação sem anestesia aí um
passou para fazer um eletrocardiograma
eu falei meu deus é leve
já o negócio com um choque com energia
por falecer já fiquei com medo nunca
vamos lá é tudo para menos na saúde ele
tem na sala manhã já foi bota anuncia
que em outra tia to atleta careca -
saber se minha vontade é de 220 é 110 já
vai ligando coisa müller mandados um
esse negócio vai me honra ao essa mulher
vai criar meu gráfico de jogador de
playstation 4 montenegro daquilo ali mas
enfim deu tudo certo só ficou mark
horton então um banco da praça quando
chegar eu to aqui tem muito bonito aí
saí do eletrocardiograma fui sentar para
esperar outra estampa a fazer o que eu
sentei estava vendo meu lá os filhos
tinha que sair e ela tinha que ficar e
ela não sabe atender o telefone estava
ensinando para que vai fazer para
atender o telefone só que ela teria
telefone mais ou menos assim fala tá
tocando por aí que eu vou atender oi não
já vão me chamar já levantou já vão me
chamar
já já vão chegar já está bom já são
muito danado emergência ligação bem e se
for da tim tiver problema de interrupção
tiver pouco tempo a dor nenhuma até
porque lá na praça que fica estável
escutou ela grita lá no hospital ou
chegando ao todo todos usando falar meu
filho seu coração é de ouro seu sangue e
sendo assim aqui eu vou até vender
porque é muito bom e foi fazer receita
gente eu não entendo que não contém as
pessoas que têm na vida como é que o
médico tem uma letra tão bons quanto
naquelas tudo isto diz tudo isto diz
tudo isto diz tudo isto diz tudo isto
estudo estudo a escrever o negócio ainda
está assim paciente ou ainda que já
falou até eu me liguei por ver um médico
ele estuda tanto na vida de astro
tantando escreve tanto tanto tanto tanto
a mão dele guga a modelo não registrasse
uma coisa que assim coisa que a ciência
não explica porque ele faz uma operação
a cirurgia ele encontra o folículo
capilar da vtr o plural do sistema de
arquivo anulado cérebro ele vai escrever
um beijo pra ir pra am
enfim tem coisa que não é só ser
explicado a letra do médico quando não é
possível mas enfim parece que envolve o
disco o tecido curto não pode estar
falando falando falando muito e aí piora
não esquece a música de fortaleza de no
teatro via sul e comprassem ingresso
tava se dia 20 às sete da noite
mas é bom que você já não era tão logo
os ingressos que você pegar um lugar
embora a platéia teatro via sul chega na
bilheteria que era o ingresso do show
doente pai copley tal
mais informações na descrição do vídeo
tá e é lógico que eles fossem que eu fiz
foi gravar esse vídeo aqui pra vocês
clique no gosto me ajudar eu quero que
você comente aqui embaixo tem que ser
mais odeia em hospital beleza beleza é
nós valeu boa sorte pra mim é seu dia